in the Lords today the Archbishop of
Canterbury has been talking about the
illegal migration Bill let's just have a
look at what he had to say it is morally
unacceptable and politically impractical
to let the poorest countries deal with
the crisis alone and cut our
International Aid
but morally unacceptable politically
impractical how do you respond to that
well good evening the House of Lords is
doing its constitutional job as a
revising chamber and of course we'll
listen to to views of the Archbishop and
his colleagues but the British public
are clear they see the unfairness in the
English Channel and they want us to take
action because you've got mostly young
men in a place of safety France with a
fully functioning Asylum system getting
into small boats fueling a trade in
organized immigration crime and then
breaking into our country in flagrant
breach of our laws no country would
stand for that and nor should we that's
why we're introduced the illegal
migration bill at the heart of it is a
very simple principle that if you come
here illegally in that manner you will
be returned either to a safe country
where you've come from like Albania or
to a safe Third Country like Rwanda this
is the only way to break the people
Smugglers hold to create deterrence and
to get back control of our borders
that's what the public expect that's
what we're doing the public certainly
expects a legal migration to be dealt
with but the point that the Archbishop
and others have made is that this policy
isn't going to achieve that it's it's
just not effective the Home Secretary
has written an open letter to the Lords
telling them this bill is the will of
the people
um but a lot of people just don't think
that your proposals actually are going
to make any difference well I
respectfully disagree I've spent several
months now immersed in this issue and I
can tell you that what makes the
difference is creating serious deterrent
ensuring that if you try to come here on
a small boat if you pay people Smugglers
you will not find a life in the UK you
will be returned back home or to a say
Third Country like Rwanda if there was a
simple solution we would have done it
already we're reaching for this because
it is robust but it's also fair and it's
going to succeed because it will produce
the crucial deterrence that breaks the
business model of the people Smugglers
and the human traffickers once and for
all and the Archbishop and others uh
raised the issue of morality well
there's nothing moral in perpetuating
the trade of the people Smugglers these
are amongst the most evil individuals in
society today and it's only by breaking
their business model decisively which is
what this this bill will do that we can
achieve that but Elders would argue that
the very easiest way to break that model
is to give safe and legal roots to the
people who want to come here no that
that is uh I'm afraid to say an
irrelevant argument because super
relevant if you can't come here legally
you're going to find another way to come
here legally in the last few years in a
very very defined small circumstances no
that that's not correct since 2015 half
a million people have come to the UK for
humanitarian reasons whether that's from
Ukraine Hong Kong Syria Afghanistan or
the global scheme which is much broader
and is operated by the United Nations
more humanitarian visas were issued last
year than in any year since at least the
second world war so those are people who
picked like Hong Kong and Ukraine well
there's also there's also a global
scheme which the UN operates where they
choose who to bring to the UK using
their expertise and we have a family
reunion scheme that helps those refugees
who have family in the UK to come here
as well and 45 000 people have come on
that scheme since 2015 and these are
very large numbers by historical and
other European standards for
resettlement schemes we're second only
to Sweden for taking people from the
United Nations we're fourth in the world
so the argument that's made by some
particularly on the left that the UK is
somehow ungenerous or the conservative
government is not committed to the UK
being a Force for good in the world and
offering Sanctuary to those genuinely in
need is not true but what is true is
that taking predominantly young men from
France is making it very difficult for
us to continue to live up to those high
standards we want to focus the resources
that the UK has on the people most in
need and to break the model of the
people's Smugglers but what is also true
is is that whatever you say about your
policy being the most effective policy
it's not the policy that the voters seem
to think let's just look at this poll
that we have which looks at how people
regard how the government has dealt with
immigration how the government's
handling immigration badly the red line
at the top just look at this over the
last couple of years 83 percent of those
questions think the government is doing
a bad job of handling immigration we're
doubling down on that policy the way
that's why they want us to take very
robust actions
what we're doing here is something that
is significantly different what we're
saying is that home secretaries have
said I'm going to stop the boats and
gone down to to the coast and and well
this is just with all states over the
last three this isn't just trying to
deter this isn't just for the last three
years this is a fundamental change to
our system it's saying that we will be a
force for good in the world with
resettlement schemes and safe and legal
routes but if you come here illegally
you will not find a route to life in the
UK that is a fundamentally different
approach to any we've done in the past
and I would just say to the labor party
or the lib Dems or those who seek to
criticize this approach what would you
do and I haven't seen any credible
policy from other political numbers of
home office workers to reduce the
backlogs that's gone up we're doubling
70 000 to 166
000 in two years and it keeps going up
so as as the numbers keep going up they
say they there is the problem is that
the people who are here aren't being
dealt with quick enough well I want to
reduce the backlog and we've got a very
good plan to do that but the idea that
you deter people from coming into the
country illegally by saying to them you
know what we'll process your claim
incredibly quickly it is very naive
getting the backlog down is the right
thing to do and we're doing it we're
doubling the number of decision makers
that the home offers but you're not
doing but this isn't going to make
people not come to the union
by the labor party you've got to be
tough in this situation because we're
dealing with determined people and
Ruthless People Smugglers and human
traffickers that's why the kind of
robust but fair approach in the bill is
the only way we're going to get on top
of this issue okay let me move on to
brexit and the EU retained law Bill Kami
badnog's made it a statement today one
of the promises of brexit was to remove
all EU legislation by the end of 2023
the business and trade ministers today
say the government's going to amend the
bill to revoke only about 600 out of the
4 000 retained EU laws was brexit worth
a paper it was written on it certainly
was and we have been doing it already in
a range of important areas we've already
set out to reform laws which we
inherited from our time in the European
Union but which we believe as a
sovereign country we can do better we've
done that in financial services we're
doing with data like gdpr that everybody
who deals with in their daily lives and
now we're setting out to remove from the
statute book more of those laws that
we've inherited from the EU and replace
them with better more innovative ways to
tackle similar challenges what we've
said today is that we're going to
prioritize the most impactful and
ambitious laws and then turn to ones
which have far less impact on society or
the economy later that you would cherry
pick which laws you wanted to repeal you
know you said that you would repeal all
EU laws into them well we'll just do the
ones that we can no we want to do that
but it's obviously sensible for a
government to prioritize and we're going
to prioritize those laws where we think
we can make the most impact in people's
lives whether that's improving
environmental standards or making our
economy more Innovative and successful
and we'll do those first and then we can
turn to the others where the impact is
much less later on when when you look at
the sunny Uplands of brexit that the
conservative party in Boris Johnson
promised us before the last election and
how you did does it fill your heart with
Dread as we approach the next election
no I think the British public were clear
that they wanted us to leave the
European Union we've delivered on that
and now this bill is an example of where
we're trying to use the new powers and
freedoms that we've got creatively to
support the British Public's Ambitions
and if I give you an example an area
like life sciences and exciting new part
of the British economy that can also
help the NHS to deliver Innovative
treatments we're going to be ensuring
that the UK has the best Frameworks it
possibly can to support scientists and
researchers but there'll be other areas
that are a lower priority and it's right
that we turn to those later on in the
process that's just a sensible good
government approach
we had the local elections last week
catastrophic by any measure really when
when it comes to how many seats the
conservative lost a thousand was touted
as a bad number it wouldn't be as bad as
that it was worse than that let's look
at the figures you lost 163 Council
seeds
um it's not very good a thousand and
sixty three I do I do beg upon um
how on Earth do you think this is going
to translate out into the general
election
well I don't think you can make a direct
comparison between local elections and
general elections and there are plenty
of examples where parties have performed
in a disappointing way in a local
election and then went online
well if you look in 2019 the last time
these uh local councils were up for
election there was a disappointing
results and we went on to win a big
majority later on in the year in the
general election nonetheless of course
we are disappointed by the results and
the loss of many very capable local
councilors including in my own
constituency but what we as a government
have to do is to focus on the issues
that the public really care about and
we've made clear what those are we want
to tackle inflation we want to get the
deficit down we want to support the NHS
by getting the backlog down there and in
my area in the home office we're focused
on securing our borders and stopping the
boats that's what we as a government are
doing because ultimately at the general
election people will say is this a
competent capable government that's
making my life better and we need to
focus on those big challenges now and
when you look at what's happened to the
economy over the last few months when
you look at the succession of
conservative leaders that we've had do
you think that people are going to think
this is the competent and capable party
hand on heart can you say that to me
well I know Rishi sunak very well and I
think he is the leader that we need at
this time eventually he is working hard
he's addressing the big issues he's
already stabilized the economy after a
very challenging period last year with
the war in Ukraine and the aftermath of
the pandemic and now of course we've got
to move forward and use this year to
deliver for the public so if I was sat
here in a year's time you would be able
to see that on the big challenges facing
the country we're clearly moving in the
right direction I'm confident in Rishi
and the team he has around him and we've
got a big task ahead of us
13 years do you think the general
population wants a government that's
moving in the right direction wouldn't
most people assume that after 13 years
you might have sorted it out well we
have achieved a lot in the last 13 years
you only have to look back at our track
record in some absolutely key areas like
education reform for example where we've
massively increased the number of young
people in good or outstanding schools
there are areas that we should be very
proud of as a government but latterly of
course we've had some huge Global
challenges haven't we we've had an
unprecedented once in a century pandemic
That Shook the kaleidoscope and meant
that there was immense pressure on our
public services and our economy we've
had a European War for the first time
since the end of the second world war
which has led to a big pressure on the
cost of living Energy prices
those are major challenges we're working
through them we're getting stability
back in the economy this year I think
will be year marked with inflation
falling significantly the economy
growing if we can also ensure that
public services are performing well like
the NHS and if my time ask we can make
progress on stopping the boats then I
hope the public will give us a good
hearing when it comes to the general
election but delivery is the key for us
now and that's what the Prime Minister
and I focused on Robert genre thank you
very much thank you